que celui qui n'a jamais utilisé
wikipédia dans ses travaux lève la main
nous avons tous un jour utiliser
wikipédia pour vérifier rapidement une
information pour débuter une recherche
ou faire un travail un article publié
dans l'obs en 2017 faisait mention d'une
enquête qui affirmait que 87% des
professeurs américains consulter
wikipédia personnellement il m'arrive
aussi d'aller très régulièrement sur
cette plateforme pour préparer des
exposés ou des leçons s'il n'est pas
forcément mauvais d'aller sur wikipédia
il est très important de ne pas le faire
n'importe comment déjà peu de
professeurs accepte qu'une bibliographie
soit composé exclusivement d'articles
tirés de wikipédia
quand les professeurs voix dans votre
biographie que vous avez utilisé
wikipédia ils ont parfois un a priori
négatif sur la qualité de votre travail
d'ailleurs les bibliographies d'articles
ou des ouvrages scientifiques renvoie
très très rarement à wikipédia et jeudi
très rarement parce que j'ai pas vérifié
si on avait eu ou pas mais j'en vois
quasi jamais alors disons le tout de
suite dire que wikipédia n'est pas un
outil fiable serait une contre vérité
wikipédia n'est pas forcément moins
fiable qu'une autre source
encyclopédique plusieurs études dont
certaines ont été publiées dans la
célèbre revue scientifique nature nous
disent que wikipedia est parfois plus
fiable dans certains cas que les
encyclopédies classique cependant il
faut bien avoir en tête que wikipedia
offre des contenus de qualité très
inégale et qu'à côté d'articles très
sérieux pertinent et précis vous aurez
des articles de moins bonne qualité il y
aura en effet des articles dans lesquels
les trolls
on aurait été actif et or ont truffées
l'article d'imprécisions d'erreurs ou de
contre vérités de plus dans certains
domaines la documentation sera beaucoup
moins importante et vous trouverez
beaucoup moins d'informations dans
certains champs de la connaissance les
auteurs sont principalement bénévoles et
donc vont écrire généralement sur ce qui
les intéresse eux sans se préoccuper de
couvrir l'ensemble des connaissances
produites par les collectivités humaines
aura même aussi une différence de
qualité entre les différentes versions
de l'encyclopédie c'est à dire contre la
version anglaise par exemple est la
version française pouvait vraiment avoir
une grande différence qualitative parce
que en fait les auteurs souvent être
différent et lartigue leur langue
française n'est pas une traduction de
l'article en langue anglaise qui traite
le même sujet alors comment faire pour
tirer profit de cet outil car il est
d'une grande facilité d'utilisation et
surtout très accessible étant donné
qu'il est déjà gratuit mais comment
faire cela sans se faire avoir répondre
à cette question nous allons nous baser
sur les caractéristiques de wikipédia
vous le savez le contenu de wikipedia
est issu d'une collaboration
online entre différents auteurs
wikipedia demande à ce que les auteurs
précisent leurs sources et ces mêmes
auteurs peuvent également débattre un
peu si un désaccord survient dans la
rédaction d'un article en conséquence
tout article de l'encyclopédie comporte
une bibliographie dans laquelle on
retrouve l'ensemble des sources
utilisées par les auteurs de l'article
mais aussi deux onglets un onglet
historique et un anglais discussions qui
vont reprendre à la fois les
modifications qui ont été portées au fil
du temps sur l'article consulter mais
aussi les échanges qu'il y a eu entre
les différents auteurs est donc là les
désaccords peuvent éventuellement
apparaître donc dans le cas où
l'information vous intéresse il vous
suffit d'aller voir au bas de l'écran
tout en bas dans la rubrique
bibliographie pour consulter la source
qui est à l'origine de l'information et
s'il se trouve que cette source est
intéressante et que finalement
l'information est très pertinente pour
votre recherche ou votre rares travail
vous abandonnerez l'article wikipédia
pour reprendre cette source primaire
dans votre travail et l'a mentionné à ce
moment-là vous même dans votre
bibliographie à vous vous serez passé
par wikipedia mais vous aurez juste fait
un passage sur cette plateforme puisque
au final vous atterrissez sur une autre
source ou un autre site qui est à
l'origine de l'information finalement
qui avait été repris par l'auteur lors
de la rédaction de l'article dans le
même ordre d'idée si vous constatez
qu'une information est vraiment très
pertinente mais qu'elle vous sommes
quand même un peu louche vous pouvez
aller voir l'historique et le fil de la
discussion pour savoir s'il y a eu des
échanges au niveau de cette information
est ce qu'il y a eu des désaccords est
ce qu'il y à une polémique ou alors est
ce qu'il y à un relatif consensus au
sein des rédacteurs wikipédia toutefois
et c'est là qu'est la limite de
wikipédia et ce ne sera pas possible de
faire une critique de chaque article de
wikipédia car les auteurs rédigent leurs
articles sous des pseudonymes
derrière ce pseudonyme finalement on ne
sait pas qui se cache et donc c'est très
compliqué finalement de porter un
jugement sur l'information qui a été
référencée dans wikipédia et c'est pour
ça que vous allez allez sur la source
même si vous pensez qu'une info et
pertinentes et fiables vous ne pouvez
pas vous arrêter à wikipédia vous devez
aller plus loin autrement dit wikipedia
vous sera très utile au début de votre
recherche surtout si vous ne connaissez
rien à votre objet d'étude consulter
wikipédia est un bon réflexe à ce stade
au début de la recherche
l'encyclopédie vous permet de faire
rapidement le tour d'une question ou
d'un objet puisque l'article est une
synthèse de différents auteurs qui ont
eux mêmes résumé synthétiser différentes
sources il s'agit d'une synthèse de ce
qu'on appelle l'état de l'art l'état de
l'art c'est le mot pour dire l'ensemble
des connaissances qui ont été formulées
par rapport à un objet mais n'oubliez
pas que la qualité de cette synthèse peu
varié et peut aussi comporter un certain
nombre de biais cependant grâce aux
astuces qui ont été dites dans cette
vidéo vous serez armes pour dépasser
cette première source et enrichir votre
recherche wikipedia n'est donc pas une
fin en soi mais un formidable tremplin
pour booster votre exploration je vous
remercie pour votre attention et je vous
dis à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo consacrée à la pratique des
sciences sociales
mais wikipédia c'est mal
[Musique]